[Applause]  westbrook with half a minute to play  westbrook in deep falls back scores  the brody  112 110 timeout  down to the wire this one is going down  to the wire 27 seconds on the game clock  24 obviously on the shot clock for miami  as  westbrook taking one a tough defender in  pj tucker  he had another basket he's fired up  little corner jump shot corner of the  elbow nothing but bottom lakers have  done a real good job of fighting back  after trailing by nine you know what  what a performance  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  westbrook brings it up  drives up tucker gets inside fall back  it's good  back-to-back buckets from westbrook  timeout miami the lakers back up by two  [Music]  russell westbrook  trying to find his game trying to find a  rhythm  back to back big time hoops and enjoy  [Music]